[Musique]
mon général c'est la première fois que
vous acceptez de répondre sur l'écran de
la télévision aux questions d'un
journaliste je voudrais donc essayer ce
soir de vous poser les principales
questions que la plupart des français
ceux qui s'apprêtent à voter pour comme
ceux qui s'apprêtent à ne pas voter pour
vous aimerez vous poser s'il était à ma
place ce soir je dirais même et brèves
ou posés depuis bien avant depuis bien
longtemps et bien avant que la campagne
électorale pour la désignation du
président de la république ne soit
engagée la première de ces questions
sera si vous le voulez bien celle-ci
vous avez écrit en tête du premier tome
de vos mémoires de guerre toute ma vie
je me suis fait une certaine idée de la
france et nous savons que cette certaine
idée de la france est élevée et qu'elle
est exigeante seulement vous voyez mon
général les français ont souvent
l'impression que vous vous faites
également deux une certaine idée est que
cette certaine idée vous faites des
français est très différente de celle
que vous faites de la france en d'autres
termes qu'elle est beaucoup moins élevé
et je crois que les français ça ne leur
fait pas très plaisir cher monsieur il
est vrai que c'est la première fois
depuis longtemps que j'ai le plaisir de
m'entretenir avec un journaliste en
particulier si j'ose m'exprimer ainsi
car il ya beaucoup de gens qui nous
voient qu'ils nous entendent
très souvent j'ai eu devant moi des
journalistes par centaines mais enfin il
est vrai que cette fois ci en voilà un
vous me parlez de l'idée que je me fais
de la france
ce n'est pas un sujet nouveau il est
tout à fait vrai je dirais que c'est ma
raison d'être il est tout à fait vrai
que depuis toujours et aujourd'hui je me
fais un effet de la france une certaine
idée
je veux dire par là qu'à mon sens elle
est quelque chose
de très grand de très particulier
c'est du reste je pense ressentie par le
monde entier
il y a même là quelque chose aux
extraordinaires
dans nos malheurs on s'en aperçoit tout
de suite et quand nous sommes heureux
prospère lorieux efforts on s'en
aperçoit aussi dans la mesure où les
gens nous regardent avec envie
c'est vrai la france est une chose à mes
yeux
très considérable très valable et
elle doit avoir dans le monde quels
qu'ils soient toutes époques
naturellement d'après les circonstances
elle doit avoir un rôle elle
il faut que la france joue son rôle
c'est exact et pour qu'elle joue son
rôle il faut qu'elle soit la france
les français les français ceux qui font
la france
c'est lui qui en sont responsables
le génération en génération
la france est plus que les français du
moment
la france vient de loin elle est ce
qu'elle est maintenant et puis à
l'avenir autrement dit la france
embrasse toutes les générations de
français
est d'abord bien entendu les générations
vivantes ces générations vivantes sont
responsables de la france et c'est ainsi
c'est vrai que je considère dans leur
ensemble les français et c'est ainsi que
je souhaite que les français dans leur
ensemble se considèrent eux-mêmes
il y a à cet égard là entre eux et pour
cela une solidarité
que je dis être national et faute de
laquelle la france risque de n'être pas
ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle est de tout
temps et par conséquent de ne plus jouer
son rôle est de ne plus à proprement
parler exister
voilà ce que je peux vous dire des
français par rapport à la france
de nous autres français
d'aujourd'hui
par rapport à la france de toujours en
général puisque nous parlons des
français je voudrais également vous dire
ceci les français ont souvent
l'impression que par nature profonde
peut-être vous êtes davantage préoccupé
de la conduite des affaires de la france
à un niveau très élevé que de leurs
propres problèmes à eux leurs problèmes
quotidiens leurs problèmes matériels on
a exprimé cela d'une façon schématique
un peu militaire en disant que vous ne
vous intéressiez pas beaucoup pas
l'intendance or les français s'ils se
sentent concernés évidemment par les
affaires de la france se sentent
également aussi très concerné par ce que
j'appellerais familièrement les affaires
de leur porte monnaie ce qu'il y a dans
leur porte-monnaie ce que ce qu'il ya
dans leur porte-monnaie leur permet de
se procurer et je me permets de vous le
dire très respectueusement mais très
franchement les français ont souvent
l'impression que vous êtes un peu au
dessus de ces contingences
on m'a prêté en effet ce mot que je n'ai
jamais dit et à plus forte raison que
j'ai jamais pensé l'intendance suit ça
ce sont des blagues pour les journaux je
n'ai pas besoin de vous dire ce que
j'entends parle
en réalité
je vous le répète les français sont
responsables de la france mais ils sont
sur la terre ils ont leur vie et pour
que la france existe il faut que les
français existent pour que la france
soit forte il faut que les français
soient prospères autant que possible
bien entendu
et cela je sais je ne dirais pas mieux
personne ne l'est certainement autant
que personne
alors voici la question et notamment la
question du jour la question plus
exactement de notre époque
qui est une époque économique et social
et on a
ce sont les démagos tranchant le mot il
faut bien le dire ce sont les partis
hirsch qui caressent les clientèles pour
être élu et souvent les journaux qui
caressent les clientèles pour être lu
alors cela assez volontiers et même très
volontiers 10 mais il en faut plus pour
intel il en faut plus pour intel il faut
faire davantage pour les ouvriers il
faut faire plus pour les paysans il faut
faire mieux pour les cadres il faut
arroser davantage les fonctionnaires les
agents des services publics il faut même
donné un petit peu plus aux chefs
d'entreprises avec un peu d'inflation
il faut beaucoup plus de logements il
faut beaucoup plus note en route il faut
beaucoup plus de téléphone il faut un
enseignement encore bien mieux organisé
avec beaucoup plus d'école à tous les
étages et d'universités etc etc
j'achèterai commode c'est vulgairement
com oui mais c'est aussi ce que les
français individuellement se disent si
vous voulez dire que je ne suis pas sur
ce plan là vous avez raison moi je suis
sur le plan que voici il faut que le
peuple français soit prospère il le faut
parce que s'il n'est pas parce père la
france dont nous parlions tout à l'heure
ne pourrait pas jouer son rôle dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui donc rien ne
m'occupe
davantage depuis bien longtemps que la
prospérité nationale
je dirais même puisqu'on vous je vais
parler d'un tendance que ça me fait un
peu sourire car si vous y faites
attention rien rien rien de ce qui a été
fait d'important au point de vue
économique et social
depuis la libération
n'a été fait
excepté par mon gouvernement
après la libération
c'était le point de vue
sociales immédiates qui l'emportait il
fallait que nous retrouvions après ces
deux secousses épouvantable il fallait
que nous trouvions notre équilibre
alors mon gouvernement
a fait les assurances sociales les
allocations familiales les
nationalisations les comités
d'entreprise etc
aujourd'hui ou plus exactement depuis
que je suis revenue depuis sept ans
c'est l'économique qui me paraît
l'emporté sur tout le reste parce
qu'elle est la condition de tous et en
particulier la condition du progrès
social c'est pas la peine de nous
raconter des histoires si nous sommes
pauvres ou en désordres économiquement
parlant
nous ne progresserons pas socialement au
contraire si nous sommes prospère et à
condition bien entendu que l'état façon
de voir tous les français en profite et
en profiteront alors justement général
est ce que nous pourrions essayer un peu
de passer en revue ses différents ces
différents domaines jeunes dont les
français quelquefois pense que les
choses comme vous dites ne vont pas
aussi bien qu'elle devrait aller d'abord
le niveau des prix le niveau de vie des
français
niveau de vie des français pas plus tard
que samedi j'aurais des chiffres à mon
avis sont éclatants
depuis ce temps je répète que le niveau
de vie des français a augmenté de 3,7
pour cent pas et que d'après ce qui est
décidé par notre cinquième plan et ce
qui est devenu possible grâce à nos
progrès économique le niveau de vie des
français est monté à 4 % par an ça veut
dire que 18 ans après mon retour 18 ans
après mon retour le niveau de vie des
français aura doublé ce n'est pas si mal
alors c'est comme le bonheur ça existe
par comparaison par contre pas raison
avant mon retour je demande que l'on
considère ce qui n était ce qui en était
c'était que les prix montaient depuis
1946 jusqu'en 1958
automatiquement en moyenne de 10% par an
et que tout ce qu'on faisait pour les
salaires prend les traitements et aussi
pour les revenus paysans et qui
dévoraient à mesure par cette
augmentation des prix
il est parfaitement exact que tout en
faisant monter le niveau de vie comme je
le dis le niveau de vie réel et bien il
est parfaitement exact que mon
gouvernement à stabiliser les prix dans
toute la mesure où à notre époque c'est
possible au lieu que les prix augmentent
de 10% par an comme c'était le cas avant
58 il augmente maintenant du dôi demi
pour cent par an il n'y a pas un pays
d'europe occidentale
où ce soit aussi
certain que les prix sont limités dans
leur ascension plus chez nous il y en a
qu'un ce sont les états unis pourquoi
parce que les états unis grâce à ce
qu'on appelle le golf exsangue standaard
comme vous savez on la facilité
d'exporter leur inflation mais nous
n'avons pas cette facilité il a donc
fallu faire le plan de stabilisation
je reconnais que ce n'était pas facile
je reconnais qu'il en est résulté des
difficultés par ci par là et notamment
au point de vue de l'expansion immédiate
mais maintenant c'est fait et par
conséquent c'est sur cette base solide
stable avec des budgets en équilibre une
monnaie qui ne bouge pas il dit prie je
vous le répète qui pratiquement
n'augmente pour ainsi dire plus et qui
comme vous le savez ne doivent pas
augmenter l'année prochaine plus de 1,5
pour cent par an c'est sur cette base là
que notre niveau de vie s'élève et que
tout le monde y gagne
voilà la réalité pour le niveau
général tout à l'heure si vous le voulez
bien nous passerons un certain nombre
d'autres questions comme les routes
téléphone vous a évoqué tout à l'heure
l'enseignement sur tout mais vous venez
de parler du niveau de vie de
l'augmentation du niveau de vie de 3 7%
par an mais excusez moi de vous dire
qu'il ya des catégories sociales en
france qui ont l'impression que ces
chiffres ma foi ce sont des chiffres
moyens et puis quel pour elle le niveau
de vie n'augmente pas et je pense en
particulier aux paysans les paysans
trouvent que leur niveau d'une
augmentation peut être raison et même
sans doute raison il y a
incontestablement un malaise paysan il y
a plus il ya un drame paysan vous le
savez s'arranger à qui le dites-vous
mon cher michel droit à qui le
dites-vous
le problème de l'agriculture française
comme était hier le problème de
l'algérie et des colonnes
comme est aujourd'hui encore car ce
n'est pas réglé tout à fait le problème
de l'enseignement
et bien c'est un problème énorme
que nous avons à regret et dont je
prétends que nous le règlement et je
mexplique
problèmes énormes d'abord problème
national
au début du siècle
et bien il y avait les deux tiers des
français qui étaient des ruraux
et aujourd'hui il y en a 20 %
évidemment il y en aura moins dans les
années prochaines cela résulte de ce
qu'on appelle
l'industrialisation nous étions un pays
essentiellement agricole avec une vie
agricole une agriculture d'ailleurs de
subsistance surtout je veux dire par là
que la plupart de nos paysans vivaient
sur la terre où ils étaient soit qu'il
en fût ce les propriétaires soit qu'ils
ont fusé locataires vivait de ce qu'elle
produisait puisque produisaient leur
exploitation l'ue avait un petit peu de
surplus alors ils le vendaient pour
acheter ce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
produire eux mêmes ce qui était en
réalité très peu de choses
au point de vue national à cause de
l'industrialisation problème une monde
puisqu'il s'agit d'un transfert colossal
de population de notre agriculture and
hate industrie ce transfert
naturellement on peut le trouver
regrettable
on peut en avoir du chagrin vous pensez
bien qu'un homme de mon âge qui très
longtemps dans sa vie a été un soldat
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui savait et qui
sait ce que la france a tiré depuis
toujours et en particulier pour sa
défense de ces paysans il est certain
qu'il ya là une transformation une
évolution qui est à beaucoup d'égards
attristante
mais c'est comme ça et le fait étant ce
qu'il est
la question est que la nation s'en
accommode et que cette évolution
nationale se fasse dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
voilà au point de vue national comment
se pose le problème paysans transfert
d'une partie
énorme de la population française de
l'agriculture à l'industrie bon c'est
bien que ça peut pas aller sans
secousses sans difficulté sans chagrin
et puis alors il ya un problème propre à
l'agriculture parce que maintenant
l'agriculture est au milieu d'un monde
économique qui pour elle est
complètement nouveau
elle est dans un monde de production de
productivité d'outillage d'un archet
qu'elle ne connaissait pas du tout autre
fois autrefois je répète c'était
l'agriculture de subsistance
on vivait chacun on était avec ce qu'on
produisait et puis voilà c'est plus
possible il faut produire ce qu'il faut
produire il faut le produire dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et il
faut voir le vent voilà comment se pose
la question à l'agriculture enfin il ya
naturellement une question
infiniment respectable et qui se pose à
chacun de nos agriculteurs
c'est la vie chez lui car là aussi tout
s'est transformé un paysan comme un
ouvrier d'ailleurs ne peut plus vivre
une veuve juive et a bien raison comme
le disait hier il y a pour un
agriculteur une question auto chez lui
une question de l'électricité pour
s'éclairer ou pour avoir la force une
question de chemin pour arriver à sa
ferme et puis alors il ya une question
de choix de ce qu'il va produire
d'organisation de ces marchés
bref une éducation de ses enfants
bref il ya
une transformation complète au point de
vue national au point de vue agricole et
au point de vue individuel pour nos
pays'' alors que fait l'état à l'heure
qu'il est l'état a pris le problème
corps à corps et il n'avait pas pris
corps à corps avec je ne revienne
sauf cependant quelque chose de très
important qui avait été fait en 1945 par
mon gouvernement et qui s'appelait la
loi sur le fermage
je passe depuis que je suis revenu
qu'est ce qu'on a fait d'abord au point
de vue général en a fait l'orientation
agricole la loi d'orientation agricole
et la loi complémentaire est alors pour
transformer l'agriculture
on a appliqué une part très considérable
des revenus collectif des revenus de
l'état je vous dirais par exemple je
vous cite ces chiffres que pour soutenir
les marchés agricoles c'est à dire pour
soutenir les prix à l'intérieur et pour
aider à vendre à l'extérieur par des
subventions et ben ont donné 500
millions par ans parle de nouveaux
francs quand je suis arrivé actuellement
on donne 2 milliard
c'est à dire quatre fois plus et pour ce
qui est du social de tout ce qui est
social dans la matière agricole et pour
l'agriculture ont donné quand je suis
arrivé 1 milliard 400 millions on donne
aujourd'hui cette bizarre je parle du
budget de 65 c'est à dire cinq fois
davantage
enfin il est vrai que nous avons voulu
mon gouvernement et moi-même avons voulu
et boulot pour compléter cette
transformation pour aider à cette
transformation notamment ce qui concerne
le revenu agricole que le marché commun
soit ouvert nous y reviendrons s'il vous
plaît tout à l'heure où même quand vous
voudrez mais il est vrai qu'il y a eu
des secousses dans le revenu agricole
comment en aurait-il été autrement mais
il est vrai aussi que notre cinquième
plan car il faut pas l'oublier nous
avons un plan c'est une loi est bien
notre cinquième plan prévoit que tous
les revenus des français de revenus de
toutes les catégories de français ce
sont les revenus agricoles qui dans les
cinq prochaines années doivent être
augmentées le plus voilà ce qui est fait
pour notre agriculture par comparaison
avec ce qui était fait autrefois gênant
je vous remercie de tout à l'heure en
parlant les paysans vous avez évoqué le
problème de l'éducation
il faisait partie des des questions que
je vais vous poser dirais pour
l'éducation note enseignement agricole
tel qui est organisée actuellement en
1965 ya plus professeurs pour
l'enseignement agricole qu'il n'yavait
d'élèves en 1957 voilà la réalité
l'enseignement en général qui préoccupe
évidemment beaucoup les français je dois
dire que les français sont absolument
effarés par l'abondance des réformes de
l'enseignement ils sont complètement
perdus quand on est père de famille soi
même on est complètement perdue donc il
y à cette abondance de réforme dans ce
segment qui semble traduire une certaine
incohérence je vous dis comme les
français le voient et puis il y à tous
les problèmes pénuriques m pénuriques
locaux etc ce sont des problèmes
extrêmement grave et je crois que les
français aimeraient bien vous les
abordez
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que le
problème de l'enseignement était un
problème fondamental est capital de
notre temps pour la france je veux dire
par là d'abord
que tous exigent que l'enseignement soit
ouvert à tous les français et le soin
tous les étals non seulement parce que
c'est juste mais aussi pour l'intérêt
national
car dans tout ça c'est l'intérêt
national qu'il faut voir aussi et bien
l'intérêt national exige que les cadres
de la nation
les petits les moyens les cadres élevé
tous les cas puisse être puisée dans la
nation tout entière dans la jeunesse
française toute entière et que par
conséquent il faut lui ouvrir l'accès à
tous les degrés de l'enseignement c'est
ce que l'on fait et bien sûr ça exige
des constructions d'écoles énorme ça
exige un recrutement de professeurs
avaient dû même dimension et ça exige
une scolarisation totale de notre
jeunesse si c'était fort là qui est en
cours savez vous que quand je suis
arrivé en
1958 et bien le budget d'avant prévoyait
pour ce qui est des dépenses concernant
l'enseignement tout entier 9% du revenu
du produit ou plus exactement du budget
français est bien
actuellement il est de 17%
voilà les chiffres ont ceci de la mesure
de l'effort qui a été accompli car avant
ce retour on avait accompli rien du tout
on dit ben pour que n'avait pas fait
assez d'écoles mais pour que vous êtes
passé à côté de m les gens qui nous
disent ça ils se sont entraînés à ce
qu'ils appelaient le pouvoir et qui n'en
était pas un pendant douze ans après mon
départ en 46 qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
quelle école anti fait quel professeur
anti recruter en masse en réalité le
problème était entier il n'avait rien
fait ils n'avaient rien prévu d'ailleurs
c'est tout naturel qu'est ce qui pouvait
prévoir et qui ce qui pouvait faire avec
leurs régies des partis mais voilà où on
en est pour l'enseignement c'est une
oeuvre qui
terminer et qui se poursuit je crois que
le plus fort effet vous avez vous-même
en général toute heure dans ce tableau
préliminaire évoqué le problème des
routes les autoroutes en particulier le
problème du téléphone j'aimerais que
vous y reveniez quand même brièvement
parce que le téléphone c'est devenu un
lieu commun ça ne marche pas en france
est incontestablement alors j'avais en
57 j'ai vu les chiffres j'ai même vu
avant de causer avec vous et bien on a
fait en
1957 on ajouté au nom des postes
téléphoniques français on en a ajouté
114000 bon et bien en 1965 on en a
ajouté deux cent dix mille voilà et
j'ajoute que dans le cinquième plan
comme peut-être vous le savez il ya un
effort très considérable qui est prévu
pour accélérer ce développement du
téléphone que tout le monde demande
aujourd'hui y compris d'ailleurs nos
campagnes et je suis du reste est le
signe évident de l'accroissement de
notre prospérité
les routes en général les autoroutes les
routes quand je suis arrivé il y avait
soixante dix sept kilomètres
d'autoroutes voilà ce qu'on l'avait fait
comme autoroutes en france sous le
régime des partis 77 km et bien il y en
a actuellement 522 km et dans le
cinquième plan il est prévu qu on en
rajoute 18 100 kilomètres à l'heure
qu'il est il n'y a pas un pays d'europe
occidentale qui fait plus de kilomètres
d'autoroutes que nous le faisons
ok un dernier un dernier problème
également qu'il faudrait aborder si vous
le voulez bien parce que ça c'est aussi
un problème d'intérêt immédiat pour les
pour les français c'est celui du
logement les français contestable mans
s'estiment mal logés estime avoir des
difficultés et à juste titre bien
souvent parfaitement raison
ce n'est pas encore une question qui
soit résolu peignant - elle a fait des
progrès évidents et je m'en vais vous en
donner des chiffres je vous dirais par
exemple que pendant les 70 ans qui ont
précédé mon retour les septs encore
procédé mort à tous on a fait je me suis
fait donner des chiffres précis je les
ai vérifiés on a fait un million trois
cent soixante dix logement voilà ce
qu'on a fait en france pendant sept ans
avant mon retour et depuis mon retour on
a fait 2 millions 400 mille logements
pendant les sept ans quand suivi mon
retour et ça augmente car à l'heure
qu'il est on en est horrible 400 mille
logements par an et rien n'empêche de
penser et j'en suis convaincu que l'on
va arriver dans un deux trois ans à 5000
logements par an voilà des chiffres et
des réalités ces logements coûte cher
souvent ces logements coûte cher c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs l'effort actuel
comme vous le savez l'effort de l'état
est dirigée surtout sur les logements
sociaux
c'est là la part la plus considérable de
l'effort de l'état en ce qui concerne le
logement c'est parfaitement exact
mon général je crois qu'il nous reste
encore deux minutes et demie je voudrais
que vous disiez quand même quelques mots
de la recherche scientifique est un
sujet difficile dans un problème
difficile et à capital que des choses
pour ne pas dire tous qui dépendent de
la recherche scientifique en 57 ont
donné 2 % de notre budget à la recherche
scientifique public c'est à dire ce que
fait l'état pour la recherche
est bien en 65 ans a donné six pour ça
et on va l'augmenter encore dans les
années qui viennent tout ça dont nous
avons parlé
et bien je n'ai pas fait tout seul
j'ai fait avec un gouvernement et je les
fais avec un parlement seulement voilà
ce gouvernement en était un et il a duré
et ce goût ce parlement a joué son rôle
c'est à dire non point il ne s'est pas
perdue dans des agitations politiciennes
il s'est concentré sur sa tâche
législatives voilà comment je le pense
en septembre nous avons largement réussi
il faut poursuivre et c'est là tout le
problème en général je vous remercie et
puisque vous avez accepté de revenir
demain devant les caméras de la
télévision non je vous donne rendez-vous
et si vous le voulez bien nous parlerons
demain de la france par rapport au monde
très volontiers c'est tentant
[Musique]